what about my 14 year old sons asking me
if I could meet anybody in the world who
I would need and the choices I always
give him are very disappointing because
they're mostly artists whose minds i
find very interesting I mean Tom
Stoppard I would love to sit in and talk
to you but the fact is that if I meet
somebody that I greatly admire even
though I myself from a person of some
stature I'm sort of tongue tied their
tongue tied and meetings need to happen
naturally I mean for example my favorite
you know one of my favorite musicians is
a me man you know I went to a Navy man
concert went backstage talk to her for a
while fascinating great great gal but
you know what is it i'm a stranger that
you know that she's invited into her you
know into her backstage in the
conversation we have a somewhat forced
so you know the people that i would most
like to meet in the world are my dearest
friends whom I see to sell them and with
whom what I get together I have
wonderful deep joyful conversations or
exuberant arguments and if in the course
of my life I can add to my friends or i
can meet you know a few great artists
with whom I develop or with whom we
develop mutual friendship I can't
imagine anything more pleasurable more
enriching in life the people I most
definitely don't want to meet you're the
high and the mighty you know I salute
them for my from the depths you know of
my bohemian being and let them go about
their life but I think it's a very
dangerous thing for an artist to try to
cultivate wealth to cultivate power if
it happens naturally that's wonderful
but you know you should always meet
people in a democracy as equals you
respect them they respect you and I
don't want to live in a court society
you know where people are currying favor
advantage and I think that's dangerous